[Music]
chris was just telling me how he felt
much more comfortable with my being here
that's nice
um
logan
i hate to tear you away dear but
the windcuts were asking about you
[Music]
well it was nice to meet you chris
[Music]
we're celebrating the work of black
filmmakers performers and the stories
they've brought to our theaters over the
past 20-plus years we're counting down
to the best reviewed black movies from
the 2000s to present day most of the
films on this list are game changing
industry shaking films that hit feeders
i got style oh everybody got style style
ain't nothing but keeping the same idea
from beginning to end everybody got it
yeah everybody can't play like i do
to compile our list we chose from the
top 100 certified fresh black films
according to the tomato meter released
in theaters since 2000. we defined black
films as those that centered on african
american stories and african-american
characters finally we ranked the movies
using a formula which takes into account
each entry's year of release and its
number of reviews collected to weigh
their tomato meter ratings we want this
thing to be raw
tell it like it is on the streets yeah
lots of pimps and holes of cussing
and kung fu karate brothers love all
that kung fu and karate do you know
karate no but i'm a fast learner i can
learn how to chop me a mother
these movies will make you laugh cry and
feel inspired so let's count down the
best reviewed black movie since 2000 all
ranked by tomato meter
[Music]
starting with number 10 spider-man into
the verse
bitten by a radioactive spider in the
subway brooklyn teenager miles morales
suddenly develops mysterious powers that
transform him into the one and only
spider-man when he meets peter parker he
soon realizes that there are many others
who share his special high-flying
talents miles must now use his newfound
skills to battle the evil kingpin a
hulking madman who can open portals to
other universes and pull different
versions of spider-man into our world
starring shmeek moore jake johnson haley
seinfeld and directed by bob priscetti
peter ramsey and rodney rothman critics
say spider-man into the spider-verse
matches bold storytelling with striking
animation for a purely enjoyable
adventure with heart humor and plenty of
superhero action
hey come on
how you doing
huh that's a copy
oh my gosh this is this is embarrassing
we wore the same jacket
hey yeah issues inside yeah i'm aware
it's a choice
theory is that all matter is composed of
at least three fundamental particles
who can solve this for x y yes
your conclusions
[Music]
mr morales moving in the dark you're
late again einstein said time is
relative right maybe i'm not late maybe
you guys are early
sorry it was just so quiet
would you like to keep standing there or
do you want to sit down
number nine dolomite is my name
performer rudy raymore develops an
outrageous character named dolomite
moore becomes an underground sensation
and star of a kung fu anti-establishment
film that could make or break his career
starring eddie murphy wesley snipes
keegan michael key and directed by craig
brewer critics say in dramatizing rudy
raymore's stranger than fiction story
eddie murphy makes dolomite is my name
just as bold brash and ultimately hard
to resist as its subject
what do you want man where's your
warranted this badge is my warrant open
up the trunk
nothing in my trunk man open the trunk
that [ __ ] ain't mad i don't know how i
got it
you're going to jail for a long time
you're going to have to take me
is there any angle that you can shoot
this way it looks like he's actually
kicking him
there's no such angle
action
i don't understand this cat
pretending like you know karate
pretending like he could be a sex
machine
little
number eight my rainey's black bottom
tensions and temperatures rise over the
course of an afternoon recording session
in 1920 chicago as a band of musicians
awaits the trailblazing performer the
legendary mother of the blues ma
reigning late to the session the
fearless fiery ma engages in a battle of
wills with her white manager and
producer over control of her music as
the band waits in the studio's
claustrophobic rehearsal room ambitious
cornet player levy who has an eye for
ma's girlfriend and is determined to
stake his own claim on the music
industry spurs his fellow musicians into
an eruption of stories revealing truths
that will forever change the course of
their lives starring viola davis
chadwick boseman glenn turman and
directed by george c wolfe critics say
framed by a pair of powerhouse
performances ma rainey's black bottom
pays affectionate tribute to a blues
legend and black culture at large
they don't care nothing about me
all they want
is my voice
[Music]
well i didn't learn that
and they're going to treat me the way i
want to be treated no matter how much
you hurt them
[Music]
they're back there right now calling me
all kind of name calling me everything
but a child of god
but they can't do nothing else because
they ain't got what they wanted yet
as soon as they get my voice down and
when they're recording machines
then it's just like i be some [ __ ] and
they roll over and put their pants on
they ain't got no use for me then
i know what i'm talking about you watch
and irvin
he right there with the rest of him he
don't care nothing about me either
he'd been my manager for six years and
the only time he had me over his house
was to sing for some of his white
friends huh i know how they do yeah [ __ ]
you colored and you can make them some
money then you all right with them
otherwise you just a dog in the alley
and i made them more money for my
records and all their mother recording
artists they got put together and then
they want to balk about how much this
session is costing them i can't see how
it's costing as much as they say [ __ ]
ain't don't pay that kind of talk no
mind
number seven moonlight
a look at three defining chapters in the
life of chiron a young black man growing
up in miami his epic journey to manhood
is guided by the kindness support and
love of the community that helps raise
him starring mahershala ali naomi harris
travante rhodes and directed by barry
jenkins critics say moonlight uses one
man's story to offer a remarkable and
brilliantly crafted look at lives too
rarely seen in cinema
i love you shadow
i do
i love you baby
i mean you ain't god love me
lord knows i did not have love for you
when you needed i know that
so you ain't gonna love me
but you gonna know that i love you
you're here
you hear me sharon
i hate you mama
uh
number six get out
now that chris and his girlfriend rose
have reached the meet the parents
milestone of dating she invites him for
a weekend getaway with missy and dean
now at first chris reads the family's
overly accommodating behavior as nervous
attempts to deal with their daughter's
interracial relationship but as the
weekend progresses a series of
increasingly disturbing discoveries
leads him to a truth that he could never
have imagined starring daniel kaluya
allison williams catherine keener and
directed by jordan peele critics say
funny scary and thought-provoking get
out seamlessly weaves its trendship
social critiques into a brilliantly
effective and entertaining horror comedy
thrill ride
yo man
they were asking me by the
african-american experience maybe you
could take this one
oh
well well
i find that the african-american
experience for me has been
for the most part very good
although
i find it difficult to go into detail as
i haven't had much desire to leave the
house in a while
we've become such homebodies yes yes yes
but even when you go into the city i've
just had no interest
the chores have become my sanctuary
get out
sorry man okay
get out
yo yeah yo show
number five night comes on
released from juvenile detention a teen
and her ten-year-old sister embark on a
quest to avenge the death of their
mother starring dominique fishbach tatum
marilyn hall james mcdaniel
and directed by jordana spyro critics
say steadily drawing viewers into its
harrowing tale with equal parts grim
intensity and startling compassion
knight comes on heralds the arrivals of
debuting director jordana spyro and her
magnetic young stars and if you knew
what my dad was
i wanted to actually if he had my dad's
address
he looked different
put in some pounds
no not that
[Music]
it's not sherison
she's crazy angel i forgot i did see him
a few months ago you cannot come with me
[Music]
angel i don't want to be with him
you don't need him you got yourself
abby why do you have a gun you're gonna
do something bad
abby come on
are you coming back with me
number four the 40 year old version
a struggling new york city playwright
finds inspiration by reinventing herself
as a rapper starring oswen benjamin
peter kim and rodda blank who also
directed the film critics say the 40
year old version opens a compelling
window into the ebbs and flows of the
artist's life and announces
writer-director star rata blank as a
major filmmaking talent with her feature
debut
no
stupid scorpio
your stingy waves mean we can't flow
and you [ __ ] libra
[ __ ] deceiver
step off gigantor no one believes you
and mr gemini
you're too feminine
can't rock your ass bigger than mine see
me
i'm focused
my sweet mid-body lust is just for those
who i trust why
because i'ma click click click torres
wow
wow
come on guys come on clap it up for your
name
thank you
number three one night in miami
on one incredible night in 1964 four
icons of sports music and activism
gathered to celebrate one of the biggest
upsets in boxing history when underdog
cassius clay soon to be called muhammad
ali defeats heavyweight champion sunny
listen at the miami convention hall clay
memorialized the event with three of his
friends malcolm x sam cook and jim brown
starring kingsley benadir aldous hodge
leslie odom jr and directed by regina
king critics say a hauntingly powerful
reflection on larger than life figures
one night in miami finds regina king in
command of her craft in her feature
directorial debut
yeah yes catches marcellus clay is the
new heavyweight champion of the world
boys
oh my goodness
okay
what cash what
why am i so pretty ah
and i'm only 22 years old there is no
way i'm supposed to be this great look
alexander the great conquered the whole
world at the age of 30. and i conquered
the world of boxing at 22 without
sustaining so much as a scratch that's
right hey ghosts
you do the math all right
when when is this party going down yeah
that's a good question what's on the
agenda malcolm well i thought this would
be a wonderful chance for us to reflect
on what's happened tonight like our
young brother said there's no denying
that greater forces were at work
you mean
no one else is coming
number two selma although the civil
rights act of 1964 legally desegregated
the south discrimination was still
rampant in certain areas making it very
difficult for blacks to register to vote
in 1965 an alabama city became the
battleground in the fight for suffrage
despite violent opposition dr martin
luther king and his followers pressed
forward on an epic march from selma to
montgomery and their efforts culminated
with president lyndon johnson signing
the voting rights act of 1965. starring
david o'yello oh tom wilkinson carmen
ijogo and directed by ava duvernay
critics say fueled by a gripping
performance from david o yellow salma
draws inspiration and dramatic power
from the life and death of martin luther
king jr but doesn't ignore how far we
remain from the ideals his work and body
troopers withdrawal
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
[Music]
mudbound mudbound follows the mcallen
family newly transplanted from the quiet
civility of memphis and unprepared for
the harsh demands of farming despite the
grandiose dreams of henry his wife laura
struggles to keep the faith in her
husband's losing venture meanwhile
happened florence jackson sharecroppers
who have worked the land for generations
struggled to build a small dream of
their own despite the rigidly enforced
social barriers they face the war upends
both families plans as their returning
loved ones jay mcallen and ronald
jackson forge a fast but uneasy
friendship that challenges the brutal
realities of the jim crow south in which
they live starring jason mitchell mary j
blige rob morgan and directed by d reese
critics say mudbound offers a well-acted
finely detailed snapshot of american
history whose scenes of rural clash
struggle resonate far beyond their
period setting
we don't belong today
we pay rent
work our crop for us that's it
they can't just pick us up settle down
like we do
you don't want to always talk about
saving i own in our own parts of the
only way to get up from under they foot
we right there i don't want you walking
for them
i won't be working for them i'd be
working for us
i already said yes
for the husband at the head of the wife
even this crosses the head of the church
an excellent wife
who can find
she's more precious than jules her
husband trusting her and he will have no
lack of gain
oh those sanders
you really are listening huh
yes
and now you must listen to me
farewell amore
after 17 years apart angle and immigrant
walter is joined in the us by his wife
and teen daughter now absolute strangers
sharing a one bedroom brooklyn apartment
they struggle to overcome the emotional
distance between them walters trying to
let go of a previous relationship while
his wife esther struggles with a new
country culture and a husband who seems
distant their daughter sylvia is a
dancer just like her father and while
she also finds her new life difficult
she bravely starts to explore the city
and show herself through dance it's an
intimate and deeply personal look at an
intergenerational tale that has defined
america since its inception starring
intare guma umbahu muwene zai navja
jamie lawson and directed by equamsangi
critics say a striking debut feature for
writer director iguam sangi farewell
amore movingly captures the fallout from
a long separated family's reunion
this country
this is very
hard for black people
especially foreigners
you always have to
carry yourself a certain way so that
white people
don't feel threatened
so when we get to dance
that's the one place where i can
actually
be myself
show myself
so be yourself you're the only one who
knows what you know
and who can do
what you do
[Music]
the hate you give
star carter is constantly switching
between two worlds the poor mostly black
neighborhood where she lives and the
wealthy mostly white prep school that
she attends the uneasy balance between
these worlds is soon shattered when she
witnesses the fatal shooting of her
childhood best friend at the hands of a
police officer facing pressure from all
sides of the community star must find
her voice and decide to stand up for
what's right starring amandla stenberg
regina hall russell hornsby and directed
by george tillman jr critics say led by
a breakout turn from a manless steinberg
the hard-hitting the hate u give
emphatically proves that the young adult
genre has room for much more than magic
and romance mama and daddy had me when
they were 17.
my nana even threw mama at the house
said daddy was no good
just a pusher for the king lord's game
you see my wallet yeah put on the
dresser i can't smile well i know it's
there maybe i'll put it there good
morning good morning she swore raising
the dead was more likely than mama and
daddy making it mama
they stay proven her and everybody else
wrong and in large part that means
making sure that we don't make the same
mistakes you know what why don't you
just sit your cute butt down and let me
do what i do okay oh really
you gonna let me do what i do
maybe too old for that
boy
good morning y'all good morning their
cuteness can be extra but they're
adorable
i love you
i can't even lie they're my otp
one true pairing
and finally number one miss june teen
a former beauty queen and single mom
prepares her rebellious teenage daughter
for the miss juneteenth pageant starring
nicole the hair kendrick sampson alexis
chicazi and directed by channing godfrey
peoples critics say like a pageant
winner walking across the stage miss
juneteenth follows a familiar path but
does so with charm and grace
if you do real good you can go to
spelman
the women coming out of there do big
things
ain't that a girl's school
remember you took me to state fair
classic and they did the battle of the
bands
dancing dolls came up
they tore it up
i got to go to college
i want to go somewhere like that
or
i can go to prairie view like you did
you worry about the wrong thing
if i make the dance team
i can get me a scholarship like you want
me to
but
them girls
did dance in high school so they got
experience ain't no school handing out
no full ride for that
i need you focus on your studies
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content that you love and
until next time i'm your host naz perez
and we'll see you back here for more top
10s on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you